Merry Christmas everybody
and honor the occasion you take a little
break from the Disney sequels and
instead look at something a bit more
Christmas oriented Bob is still a
direct-to-dvd movie that Mickey's once
upon a Christmas every year I see this
brought out and I've never really seen
before because I think it came out a
little past my time and that I love
Disney but it's kind of the basic Disney
cartoons it's Mickey Donald goofy all
learning about the meaning of Christmas
law hijinks ensue I kind of assumed
there wasn't that much adult stuff in it
and yeah it does seem mainly for kids
but for a Christmas movie a mainly a
kids I think it's done pretty good it's
an anthology of stories each dealing
with the holiday the first one centers
around Huey Dewey and Louie and them all
wishing that Christmas could be every
day yeah you know this tale and you kind
of know what comes of it they get
Christmas every day at first they love
it but then they find they don't and
eventually a lesson is learned it's
pretty standard until they've drawn a
little bit of a twist where once the
boys get sick of it they start to act up
and make things worse this results in
them seeing the consequences of their
actions on the rest of family and I
don't know I thought that added a little
bit more at least from what you usually
expect of this story it's kind of nice
and there's a nice little bit about a
Christmas card that you think it's a
throwaway joke but it makes a return to
and I don't know it was actually pretty
emotional ideas I liked it the second
centers around goofy and his son Max
actually a much younger version of Max
which I really like I kinda like the
idea of seeing him at a different age
but then again they probably did that
because it's about his belief in Santa
Claus in that he's starting to doubt
next-door neighbor pete eles and that
there's not a Santa Claus so max is
bound to find out if that's true or not
the one bizarre twist is that goofy
believes there's a Santa Claus too and
actually ends up staying out all night
until he comes this one is mostly pretty
good but I don't know I thought the
ending was a bit of a cop-out not to
give anything away but they do reveal
whether he exists in this world or not
and I don't know I thought you have done
this without a
to answer like maybe they go to bed they
wake up in the morning and find the
gifts and then you don't really know if
goofy did it or if it was just an act I
don't know I felt there was a really
smart good ending to this and they just
kind of do the traditional route but
honestly the rest is so good especially
with max trying to make his father feel
better and that I think is fine the
third and final one stars Mickey and
Mimi re-enacting the Gift of the Magi
yeah
they actually call it that I really
think that's cool I usually don't care
from Mickey Mouse stories but honestly
Mickey and Minnie are kind of the
perfect people to tell this story you
all know this tale make you want to get
a gift for Minnie Minnie wants to get a
gift from Mickey but neither of them
have a lot of money so Mickey has a plan
involving his harmonica and Minnie has a
plan involving her watch and all right I
won't give it away if you haven't seen
it buddy it's a very decent telling of
the story Mickey and Minnie are the
epitome of wide-eyed innocence that it
really does make sense to do the story
with them that's a good humble telling
all the stories are tied together with a
narration from Kelsey Grammer the minute
you hear his voice doing the whimsical
inspiring thing you just kind of
laughing giggle at how corny it is but
you're also kind of admire how sweet it
is and that's the best way to describe
this movie corny but sweet the animation
is really good especially considering it
just kind of a Disney cartoons I mean
they didn't have to throw all of his
money into it but they did and they
really tried to make it look nice and
Christmassy there's a lot of nice little
touches too if you know the Disney
Universe for example one of these
ornaments is from the second Beauty and
the Beast will be Minnie works for
Mortimer's which is this classic Disney
villain eating all the characters are
kind of tied into each other like one
person one story might be the neighbor
to another person in another story it's
kind of clever that way there's even a
couple laughs in there there's one
involving goofy finally spotting Santa
Claus that literally made me laugh so
hard and so loud I think my neighbors
walking by heard me I won't give it away
but it was a really funny scene so yeah
this is obviously something meant for
little little kids but something for
little little kids go it has a lot of
charm and delight
it's probably not something I will put
on a lot around Christmastime but I
think it's great to show your kids and
kind of get them the culture and some of
these classic stories and some news
stories as well with your favorite
Disney characters there's clearly effort
that went into it and the effort pays
off
you get three nice gentle stories that
are phenomenal both are effective each
one has a legitimately emotional moment
and each one has wanted to laugh in it
as well
definitely a nice one to check out
around the holidays there's plenty more
Disney sequels along the way but until
then Merry Christmas and enjoy the best
day of the year
[Music]
you